so python has this giant ecosystem of
packages uh and there's a package
repository do you have ideas of how to
do that well for Mojo
yeah how to do a repository of packages
well so that's another really
interesting problem that I knew about
but I didn't understand how big of a
problem it was uh python Packaging
a lot of people have very big pain
points and a lot of scars with python
packaging Oh you mean uh so there's
several things building and distributing
yes managing dependencies and versioning
and all this stuff so from the
perspective of if you want to create
your own package yes yeah and then or
you want to build on top of a bunch of
other people's packages and then they
get updated and it's like this now I'm
not an expert in this so I don't know
the answer I think this is one of the
reasons why it's great that we work as a
team and there's other really good and
smart people involved
um the uh but one of my
one of the things I've heard from smart
people who've done a lot of this is that
the packaging becomes a huge disaster
when you get the python and C together
and so if you have this problem where
you have a code split between Python and
C now not only do you have to package
the C code you have to build the C code
C doesn't have a package manager right C
doesn't have a dependency versioning
management system right and so I'm not
experienced in the state of the art and
uh all the different python package
managers but my understanding is that's
a massive part of the problem and I
think Mojo solves that part of the
problem directly heads on now one of the
things I think we'll do with the
community and this isn't again we're not
solving all the world's problems at once
we have to be kind of focused start with
is that I think that we will have an
opportunity to reevaluate Packaging
right and so I think that we can come
back and say okay well given the new
tools and Technologies and the cool
things we have that we've built up
because we have not just syntax we have
an entirely new compiler stack that
works in a new way maybe there's other
Innovations we can bring together and
maybe we can help solve that problem so
almost a tangent to that question from
the user perspective of packages
it was always surprising to me
that it was not easier to sort of
explore and find packages
you know with with Pip install and it
just it feels uh it's an incredible
ecosystem it's just uh interesting that
it wasn't made it still I think not made
easier to discover packages to do yeah
like uh
uh search and Discovery as YouTube calls
it well I mean it's kind of funny
because this is one of the challenges of
these like
intentionally decentralized communities
and so I don't know what the right
answer is for python I mean there are
many people that
were I don't even know the right answer
for Mojo
so there are many people that would have
much more informed opinions than I do
but but it's interesting if you look at
this right open source communities
um you know there's git git is a fully
decentralized anybody can do it any way
they want but then there's GitHub
right and GitHub centralized commercial
in that case right thing uh really help
pull together and help solve some of the
discovery problems and help build a more
consistent community and so maybe
there's opportunities for something like
a GitHub yeah although even GitHub I
might be wrong on this but the the
search and Discovery for GitHub is not
that
great like I still use Google Search
yeah well I mean make it maybe that's
because GitHub doesn't want to replace
Google Search right and I think there is
room for specialized solutions to
specific problems but sure I don't know
I don't know the right answer for GitHub
either that's I think they can go figure
that out but the point is to have an
interface that's usable that's
accessible to people of all different
skill levels well well and again like
what what are the benefit of Standards
right standards allow you to build these
next level up ecosystem and next level
of infrastructure or next level of
things and so
um again come back to I hate complexity
see C plus python is complicated it
makes everything more difficult to deal
with it makes it difficult to Port move
code around work with all these things
get more complicated and so I mean I'm
not an expert but maybe Mojo can help a
little bit by helping reduce the amount
of C in this ecosystem and make it
therefore scale better so any kind of
packages that are hybrid in nature would
be a natural fit to move to Mojo which
is a lot of them by the way yeah
a lot of them especially they're doing
some interesting stuff computational
wise